any doctor while I was gone fine sir
thank you how can we help you yes I'll
just call them today I'm kind of new to
your product I just heard about it the
other day on the interview you did with
Benny Hinn okay
I have this I just ordered some product
I haven't got it yet my order in the 90
mm to point out but and but I've had
this what's rope for about six months
now and it comes and goes throughout the
day it's not it's not confident I've
been for the last probably eight seven
eight years I've been back for to the
doctor about just kind of swallowing
issues and so last January just had a
where they went down with I forget what
it's called upper jaw Skippy mmm okay
everything out I said they didn't find
anything they did find a ring so they
dilated that but it came back benign for
Squamish mm-hmm let me ask you a
question
let me ask you a question you have any
other issues any high blood pressure
diabetes arthritis no okay do you have
any ringing in the ears any chime you
know receding gums loose teeth anything
like that green ears every once in a
while okay yeah okay kind of like you
have some wax in your ear kind of thing
good but I mean it kind of every once in
a while I'll have like that I don't
where it feels like an ache just in
there and then it go anyway okay what
about your neck if you turn your Jill
hold your body still but you turn your
head your chin to the left
that's your left shoulder your chin to
the right side your right shoulder you
get any grinding or popping oh no
grinding or popping no okay how much you
weigh 140 how tall are you sir okay all
right well
sharmini you there I'm here yeah
remember let's see here
remember that gal from Michigan
who had voice problems yes
and her husband yes yeah and of course
the doctors look for physical things and
they couldn't find anything in this
guy's throat you know in in Jack's
throat and so forth but he every once
awhile you'll get a little something
going on in his ears and I think that
he's got the same thing that gal had
okay which is the squeezing of the ninth
cranial nerve and night there's 12 pairs
of cranial nerves come out of each side
the ninth cranial nerve is called the
glosso pharyngeal nerve controls the
sensory and the motor functions of the
throat the pharynx that kind of the back
of the throat for the tonsils are and
also the it also affects and controls
the Seas the voice box if you will in
the vocal cords so do you have any
trouble ever with your voice you ever
feel like you're losing your voice a
little bit or anything like that Jack a
raspy voice and I kind of have for a
while okay okay so the voice is changing
yep okay and so what would you give this
guy what would you give Jack I would
give him uh I give him a healthy brain
and heart pack and then I would add some
gluco gel for those issues and vitamin
d3 and get him on a gluten-free diet
mm-hmm okay and you're exactly right
yeah okay yeah that should do okay so
yeah I would exactly get rid of all the
bad stuff all the inflammatory things
Jack as the fried foods processed meats
oils glutens wheat brought her a dose I
believe in showers tripped onto this I
believe you have osteoporosis of the
skull when you do the canals the tunnels
that these 12 cranial nerves come
through begin to get filled with bone
matrix we're just kind of the rebar the
art bone people forget you get
osteoporosis of the skull just like you
do your long bones your pelvis your
vertebrae in your ribs and everything
doctors never tell you that Dennis there
but the squeezing that ninth cranial
nerve causing the Rams fetus in your
voice that little ringing in the ears
once a while and also the change in the
voice and the sort of soreness in your
throat it's kind of like a peripheral
neuropathy I Atticus Roche if you will
so shard is you have your right one
healthy brain and heart pack I'd get an
extra bottle of house you FX plus you
can take two ounces of that pounce
practice on sitter get two bottles of
the vitamin D tree so you take three
those are breakfast and dinner
everything else you cut in half a half a
dose of breakfast and dinner time and
wouldn't hurt to get the CM cream so you
can put some CM crane down in both ears
like a quarter of teaspoon you wake up
in the morning with a q-tip like you're
trying to get wax on your ear to try and
reduce the inflammation at the roots of
those nerves and then call us in two
weeks in four weeks in six weeks
it's one of those things where we see
this actually quite often and doctors
miss it dentist miss it and a EMTs miss
it but hmm
I think we can help you out here so give
us a call in two weeks in four weeks in
six weeks you start the diet immediately
Washington state easy
West Coast you should be able to get the
products in a day or two on the west
coast out of our California warehouse
and we will walk you through that